bonsoir bonsoir Patrice pourquoi acheter
les Alouettes c'est vous qui lâchez ce
point québécart là exactement
vous avez vu qu'il y avait une
problématique au niveau de la succession
de l'ancien propriétaire
la Ligue pour tour de raison qui ne
m'appartiennent pas décidé de racheter
l'équipe et d'être décembre lorsque il a
été fait mention qu'on souhaitait
éventuellement avoir une implication
locale plus importante plus vous en
douter et ça sonner des cloches assez
rapidement chez moi et puis je me suis
mis
un secret vous êtes je suis dans les
médias alors je lis les journaux je
regarde la télé et j'ai constaté que il
y avait une situation qui a devenait
alors tout ça m'a amené à
m'engager dans des conversations des
discussions et puis
honnêtement et c'est comme ça aussi que
je pense que nous avons retenu
l'attention et du commissaire et des
gouverneurs parce que c'est comme un
club là que nous étions à mesure ou que
j'étais et nous c'est parce que bon
québécois c'est un peu moins aussi là
c'est mon père donc que nous étions en
mesure de l'amener de la valeur ajoutée
mais les avons convaincu assez
rapidement vous auriez pu passer par
québécart très bien pourquoi vous oui et
non je pense que c'est souhaitable que
nous que je le fasse personnellement
pour une raison assez simple il est de
notoriété publique que l'entreprise perd
de l'argent il faut financer les pertes
évidemment je souhaite que nous
puissions ou que je puisse le rendre la
rentabiliser à terme mais vous savez
donc une entreprise publique moi comme
PDG et je suis un fiduciaire des
intérêts des actionnaires alors est-ce
que on va se reposer des questions à
tous les trimestres par les analyses
financiers à l'assemblée annuelle par
des actionnaires vous êtes qu'est-ce que
vous faites là-dedans combien vous avez
perdu etc ou investi toute bon alors
le bilan je pense que québécois a des
beaux défis beaucoup de beaux chantiers
aussi donc
vous l'avez dit ça ne fait pas d'argent
ça ne fait pas d'argent une équipe comme
les Alouettes est-ce que ça peut enfin
éventuellement
des bénéfices intensifs le fait d'être
prêt ou associé à une équipe de football
à l'intérieur de l'ensemble canadien
pour nos activités chez québécois
notamment particulièrement et cette
aventure qui est devant nous c'est à
dire le sans fil dans plusieurs autres
régions du Canada notamment la grande la
Grande-Bretagne j'allais dire la
Colombie Britannique
l'Alberta l'Ontario et le Manitoba
des opportunités qui seraient
susceptibles de se présenter et qui
pourront justement mettre à contribution
notre participation ma participation à
l'intérieur des Alouettes combien ça
coûte une équipe comme ça là je suis
assujetti à une attente de
confidentialité vous pouvez vous en
douter j'ai la respecter je respecte
tous les engagements que nous prenons
les droits de télévision de la Ligue
canadienne de football ont été donnés à
Bel média jusqu'en 2025 ont été achetés
est-ce que c'est le genre de choses que
vous pourriez vous pourriez être
intéressé honnêtement je pense que la
Ligue va être intéressée à faire en
sorte que la compétition c'est ou de la
concurrence effectivement et qui va en
bénéficier c'est la Ligue et ce sont les
membres de l'équipe ou le monde les
membres de la Ligue que sont les équipes
de la Ligue canadienne de football alors
tout ça va participer à l'enrichissement
collectif et je convaincu que les
dirigeants de la Ligue comme d'ailleurs
ce qui s'est produit ou comme ce qui se
produit en permanence pour les autres
ligues de sport professionnel on peut
penser à la Ligne nationale de hockey il
a été une concurrence
antérieurement les droits appartenait à
belle ou précédemment à Radio-Canada
Radio-Canada aussi ont été capable de
faire un chèque qui était celui on sait
que des droits pour la transition des
droits sportifs ont augmenté de façon
extrêmement importante depuis les 20
dernières années mais si vous voulez un
jour si ce marché-là puis forcément ça
vous intéresse TVA sport doit rester en
vie et bien en vie oui et j'espère que
effectivement ça va pas bien là ça va
bien et c'est clair que ça va pas bien
on a investi des sommes extrêmement
importantes près de 200 millions de
dollars depuis donc l'inauguration et on
considère que on n'a pas été traité
équitablement donc le plus important
distributeur de TVA sport après
évidemment Vidéotron c'est belle et
belle nous donne pas donc la redevance
auquel nous croyons avoir droit et la
redevance également aussi qui est payé
par les autres distributeurs ici au
Québec dont notamment Cogeco et donc une
TELUS pour pour l'est de la province ou
de l'est donc toute la Gaspésie à partir
de Rimouski pour régler ça dans votre
esprit il faut régler ça avant et ils
vont avoir un arbit que nous souhaitons
qui puisse se produire le plus
rapidement possible on va faire valoir
ces arguments là pourquoi et un
traitement de faveur pour RDS de la part
de belles et alors que il y a
malheureusement un désavantage indus qui
est imposé à TBA sport et en attendant
cette amusant parce que belle
va diffuser des matchs des Alouettes et
il y aura des publicités de Vidéotron
partout puis de on verra bien alors mais
c'est sûr
vous allez pouvoir être un commanditaire
important de je pense que effectivement
donc les opportunités de cette nature
qui vont pouvoir se présenter et on
entend bien évidemment les exploiter
adéquattements au moment important je le
disais d'entrée de jeu c'est Léo
d'endurant que lancé l'équipe 1946 un
franco-américain c'est le seul
francophone de toute la chaîne des
propriétés vous êtes donc le deuxième
francophone uniquement le fait français
inutile d'insister pour les gens il vous
connaissent c'est important
votre entraîneur chef parle pas français
est-ce que c'est un problème non c'est
pas un problème et de toute façon donc
vous avez
l'intention de continuer à travailler de
la même façon que j'ai toujours
travaillé vous le savez on nous avons
des équipes de hockey junior Patrice
Patrick dirige les remparts c'est lui le
patron des remportes pas moi c'est même
pas Martin Tremblay qui est son patron
immédiat c'est la même chose pour
l'Armada ce sont les experts c'est eux
qui vont faire en fait des joueurs plus
de francophones que j'ai déjà assez de
travail à faire beaucoup de jeunes
enfants que j'adore
à la direction je veux plus de joueurs
francophones il y en a déjà quand même
pas mal et puis vous savez quoi avec
tout l'investissement qui s'est produit
depuis les 20 dernières années dans le
football l'universitaire je pense qu'ils
vont avoir de plus en plus la preuve
d'une certaine façon c'est que pour la
première fois de notre histoire on a
quand même eu un Québécois faire le
soupe ball c'est pas rien et c'est vrai
je qu'est-ce qui va se produire avec les
Alouettes mais toute les Québécois les
Québécoises étaient fiers de voir un
Québécois participé au super bon pour la
première fois tout à fait et il y a
cette produit des joueurs il y a des
très forte équipe universitaires
maintenant au Québec le rouge-gorge moi
j'habite à Outremont à côté de septum là
je vais vous dire un truc le 4 il y a
une partie on l'entend donc il y a pas
juste les joueurs il y a l'atmosphère
comment vous allez faire pour que les
plus de partisans d'abord parce qu'il y
en a moins là le stade est pas à guichet
fermé de retrouver une certaine fièvre
une fierté vous avez parlé de fierté
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de cette équipe de
Montréal quand vous allez faire
je crois avoir nous avons les moyens et
les outils nécessaires pour faire la
promotion pour parler encore davantage
de ceux et celles qui composent notre
équipe de pouvoir et ça c'est une belle
illustration d'ailleurs le camp
d'entraînement va avoir lieu à
Trois-Rivières est-ce que on peut
éventuellement penser que il va avoir un
attachement encore plus considérable
pour l'ensemble du Québec et pas
uniquement pour le samedi ça vous prend
plus de fans plus de monde qui vont plus
victoires
alors ça va prendre un investissement un
investissement pour s'assurer qu'on va
avoir des des joueurs qui sont investis
qui ont cette volonté donc de gagner
votre entraîneur
ça sera à lui des déterminer mais c'est
ça que ça serait une bonne chose pour
lui personnellement j'en suis convaincu
comme ça il va pouvoir être en mesure
d'échanger encore plus facilement avec
avec ceux et celles qui l'entourent
combien il ne reste de temps je veux
vous parler absolument aujourd'hui à
Star Wars c'était assez 18 qui était les
gens de Google étaient en comité il y a
aussi 11 aussi qui veut forcer les
grandes plateformes à investir au Canada
dans le contenu est-ce que ça va dans la
bonne direction selon vous ces deux
projets de loi-là et les efforts du
gouvernement fédéral pour répartir la
tarte un peu plus justement pour des
gens comme vous oui oui tout à fait j'ai
eu l'occasion également aussi de me
présenter au Comité sénatorial l'analyse
de ces deux projets de loi
je dirais même que tout le monde veut
être un petit peu d'accord avec ça que
nous sommes en retard parce que ces
problématique là se posent partout en
accident même en Australie et puis ils
ont pris les moyens nécessaire pour
faire en sorte de rééquilibrer ce qui
est essentiel parce que c'est pas les
gaffe qui produisent l'information
locale il la prennent et il la diffuse
on peut avoir un débat sémantique oui
mais ça va permettre
cette information-là d'avoir une plus
grande envergure oui mais ça va
également aussi permettre à ces gaffe à
ces entreprises d'avoir un intérêt de la
part de la population des citoyens des
citoyens des auditeurs et des auditrices
alors c'est comme n'importe quoi dans la
vie si le droit de la propriété
intellectuelle nous que ce soit l'état
par le biais de Radio-Canada ou que ce
soit des entreprises privées et TVA et
les autres belles pourquoi on serait
piqué notre contenu sans avoir une juste
donc
les fermetures de journaux puis
la terminaison également aussi de
d'autres médias c'est pas depuis hier
que ça se produit ça se produit depuis
une dizaine d'années
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes en retard il y a eu un peu de
politique ou même beaucoup de politiques
la taxe Netflix un moment donné mais non
pourquoi un véhicule comme Netflix ne
serait pas assujetti à la taxe de vente
donc il y a eu un espèce de melting bot
là où est-ce que on souhaitait créer de
la confusion au moins il a les choses
c'est clair c'est on sait très bien où
est-ce que nous nous en avons ça veut
pas dire que toutes les choses sont
réglées parce que là mais là ce que
c'est art ici votre checker qu'est-ce
que waters je pense que c'est juste
rémunération qui est là qui est
importante et je suis certain que c'est
également aussi la priorité pas
uniquement du gouvernement mais
également aussi de tous les
parlementaires parce que c'est une
question
vous en avez parlé quand on a eu vos
résultats financiers c'est une question
de survie pour plusieurs médias une
question aussi de quelle mesure on peut
réinvestir dans du contenu ici
les gens peut-être prennent pas la
mesure de l'importance de ces débats là
c'est important
et si il y a pas de moyens financiers
qui sont procurés aux entreprises de
médias les médias privés comme n'importe
quoi dans la vie ils vont disparaître là
il y a pas de miracle en cette matière à
moins que des bonnes des bonnes œuvres
qui c'est pas possible non plus on voit
que peut-être avec un modèle comme la
fraise qui est un modèle plus coopératif
bon ça pourrait éventuellement pas
coopératif là je parle probablement
peut-être plus les courbes d'information
mais le modèle de la presse ou est-ce
qu'on fait appel également aussi au
lecteur ou électrique donc de participer
financièrement un petit peu le devoir et
loger à la même enseigne est-ce que ça
fait des enfants forts pas
nécessairement je pense qu'une
entreprise rentable fait des enfants
forts et puis lorsque on faisait de
l'argent on investit de façon
significative que ce soit ici à Montréal
et à Québec mais également aussi dans
l'ensemble des régions du Québec vous le
papier au Journal de Montréal on touche
pas ça
le papier le support on a cessé vous
êtes au courant l'impression donc du
dimanche une journée puis on est le même
loin d'être les seuls l'avoir fait
maintenant qu'est-ce que l'avenir nous
réserve je suis pas un devin en cette
matière mais je suis obligé de réitérer
le fait que le marché n'est pas
favorable et circonstances ne sont pas
positives et c'est ce que je répète
depuis un certain temps maintenant comme
dirait l'autre à l'impossible de le
détenu moi je pourrais pas tenir le fort
comme ça de vitam æternam si on n'est
pas en mesure de pouvoir considérer
avoir une rentabilité au moins minimale
puis vous dites que par exemple la
télépubic prend trop de la tarte
publicitaire privée puis que ça vous
aide pas
Radio-Canada devrait cesser de vendre de
la publicité parce que la télévision
généraliste comme TVA la seule et unique
source de revenus c'est la publicité et
s'il y a tout est affaire puis c'est
vrai pour la télé mais c'est vrai
également aussi sur le web alors il y a
pas de j'adore moi je fais un auditeur
systématique de Radio-Canada la radio
mais c'est fantastique aussi
on finit sur une très belle note et
j'apprécie également aussi Céline
Galipeau qui fait un très beau travail
bah non Dieu sait hein les patrons m'ont
envoyé cet extrait de vidéo partout tu
es pédago est-ce qu'on va vous voir avec
votre truc votre famille parler de votre
femme dans les les
enthousiasme
ok on habite à côté en plus de ça très
bien super ado merci de nous voir à la
prochaine au revoir